There are exactly two types of lifters.
Those who read research, or as we call
them, scientists, and those who don't,
who are simply bros. Now, this is a
universal truth across all disciplines,
even in fields that have no research.
Ascended to chess grandmaster, bro.
Master Chef, unless you made that flaunt
in a lab, you're a bro. What about MMA
coaches? Well, somewhere there's a study
that was looking at what the average
successful submission was across 12
different white belts, and I didn't see
you reference it, so you're a bro. Now,
in all fields, but especially lifting,
we don't listen to bros because bros are
on steroids, and steroids make you reach
your natty limit in two months, and that
invalidates all of your work as a
scholar and coach. In fact, bros need to
listen to scientists. The king of all
bros, Ronnie Coleman, was known for his
highintensity, high volume, ball
busting, barbell, and dumbbell based
workouts. But despite weighing over 300
lb on stage, he would have been bigger
if he followed the evidence.
>> Short answer is they would all have
bigger quads with less injuries if they
trained more. like we're saying. Yes.
Yes. Absolutely. Yeah.
>> But he didn't have any evidence. So
instead, he'll have to settle for being
the greatest to ever live. Now, bros
will often try to appeal to vibes based
language like practical experience and
historical precedent. And they only do
that so they can shoehorn in their silly
bro methods. But it's vitally important
that you discard all of that. Instead,
you want to simplify your training to
individual variables. And you want to
understand that at any given time, this
variable is what all your gains are
going to hinge on. After 6 months of
digesting stretch mediated hypertrophy
literature, you might wonder if the
stretch isn't also influenced by the
other variables in the workout. You're
obviously mistaken, and I'll forgive
your weak character this time, but to
set you straight, here's 10 more videos
on the stretch. Even if we thought that
training is something that should be
evaluated holistically, we don't have
any research on it. So, it's basically
pagan worship. Looking at training as an
entire system is no different than
sacrificing animals to Mllo on Epstein
Island. I mean, here's an example.
Imagine you're making a dish for a
cooking contest and you decide to
consult the head of the brand new
culinary science department at the local
college. Over the decades, they have
compiled tens of studies that collected
data on average ingredients used in
baking. Hey, I was wondering how much
salt I should use in my 3 tablespoons is
the optimal amount. How How do you know
that? Well, last month we looked at 18
different dishes on Pinterest. We just
calculated the average salt usage on the
ones that got four and a half stars.
Three tablespoons. You're welcome. But
what? Like different dishes? I think
there were a few kiches in this one. A
tiramisu, couple of vegan recipes. This
doesn't seem intelligent. Now, at first,
you might think that the different
ingredients in each dish might react
differently with the salt or that some
dishes might involve bigger proportions.
But this is again just pagan witches in
your ear trying to move you towards
Satan. Obviously, you trust the science,
so you just put the three tablespoons of
salt in the dish and stop asking so many
[__] questions. Now, if you haven't
caught on yet, the important takeaway
here is that science is absolutely
paramount. And the best indicator of
good science is to see if it feels
sciency or not, and that's the only way
you're going to pull out the best
methods. You see this cable thingy on
the floor? Yeah, I bet you never would
have thought to do that one, huh? Then
what would you have done? Rows and pull
downs, presses and raises, idiot.
Thankfully, we live in a time of
science. Now, once again, your
skepticism might lead you to ask, "Do we
know that this actually provides
superior results over a long period of
time and highly trained individuals?"
Well, my friend, I've got a study of
nine kids working out over a single
college semester that tells you it does.
Now, as you take your liberties pieceing
together these little bits of science
into your Frankenstein's monster of
evidence-based training, you want to
make sure that you are extremely
confident about your model of the world.
See, people like watching science-based
content for one reason, and that is
because they trust the science to get
them jacked. And you don't want to
betray their trust or lose their
attention by talking about nuance too
long. You want to be sure to use the
word optimal when describing your model
of the world so that people do in fact
know that what you're prescribing is
better than anything else they could
potentially do. You also want to make
sure to change that model every few
years to accommodate whatever individual
topic is in the general zeitgeist at the
moment. It's really important to stay
relevant. And guys, you know, science
evolves. So, nobody's really going to
judge you for flip-flopping. As long as
you're just as confident as you were
last time, it's going to be all right.
Now, eventually, you will have multiple
conflicting models that you have
represented as being the optimal
science-based way to train. But this is
actually desirable because what you can
do is write an ebook for each one and
then just pick which one to promote
based on whatever people are talking
about right now. It's kind of like
Starbucks having a seasonal rotating
drink selection. Also, make sure all of
your material is labeled according to
science because you sure don't want
people to think you're just making this
up as you go. And you want science to
get credit for all of this crystal
clarity that you're providing. An
important thing to know in your
communication is that non-science-based
bros are dumb as [__] So you have to
communicate science to them with
confidently strong language. Ideally,
you should reduce the abstract of any
research that you cite to a single
sentence. Present the difference
observed in the study as some truth that
can be generalized universally and then
add in some flare, some adjectives in
all caps to really drive it home. Back
in the day, I used to train a lot of
middle-aged housewives, and I was always
just super elated when they came to a
session with a new nugget of truth that
they picked up by watching Oprah or
reading Women's World. What's that,
Linda? Chocolate helps you lose weight.
Well, you get a gold star today. Way to
be ahead of the curve. And thankfully,
exercise science today has studs like
Menow Henselman and Mike Israel, who've
really just captured the women's world
era of communication. Guys, if you want
to hit the holy trifecta of gains, the
size, the strength, and of course, the
clout, you need a program that checks
the biggest boxes. Not only does it use
the best time-t tested movements that
you are actually likely to stick to and
improve on, but it includes a logical
progression that is based on my most
popular programs. These are programs
that have gotten rave reviews from
people that literally just ran the
template. Base strength AI uses three of
the most proven templates pulled from
the principles of some of the biggest,
strongest men in history that have been
used for over a century. The workouts
are fun, intuitive, there's a logical
progression, but it does take it up a
notch because it personalizes the
workouts to you. As you get bigger,
stronger, more advanced, it becomes
harder to tick those numbers forward,
and you can't get by not adjusting your
workouts to your own particular
tolerances. And most people get an
online coach to take care of that for
them to the tune of $200 to $300 a
month. And the rest of the people just
never figure it out to begin with. So,
if you're wondering why you start every
training cycle super excited only to get
several weeks in, feel brittle,
overtrained, tired, disillusioned, like
you're just a dodgeball and the program
is the side of a building, then you need
direction that update your training
minute to minute, day to day, week to
week based on your immediate feedback.
Bay Strength AI takes the guesswork out
of training and it does what only an
online coach can do, which is
personalize the program to you at a
tenth of the cost. Yes, a tenth of the
cost. So, jump on the heart and soul of
old school training. It's my
programming, but it is your program and
you cannot get that anywhere else. Hit
up basrength.com today to get started on
your gain. Now, be aware that people are
going to try to curb your efforts by
adding a bunch of erroneous rules to how
research should be handled and
discussed. They'll claim how hard
statistical analysis is, that the
research hasn't been replicated, the
sample sizes are small, and the
differences aren't clinically
significant. And they might even try to
pull a fast one by claiming you're not
qualified to read the research. This is
of course just gatekeeping. Science is
nothing if it's not inclusive. So it is
absolutely vital to keep standards at an
appropriate level so that we can
accommodate more scientists. Understand
that even PhDs are overrated.
>> PhD isn't some kind of proof of your
superiority. It is step one in an
academic research career which most
people don't even end up taking.
>> Think of it like a driver's license.
Passing your test doesn't suddenly mean
you're maxen. the highest educational
rank that you can get is really just a
first step like getting a driver's
license. And this is an apt analogy for
Milo because scientists closely edged
out his second career choice which was
being a taxi driver. Now, while having
an education is completely optional for
accurately interpreting research data,
getting a PhD also does make you an
expert in everything else. Israel's PhD
is also why he's a black belt in
jiu-jitsu. In addition to that, it's
made him an expert in geopolitics,
psychology, racial dynamics, and the
future of artificial intelligence. So
remember kids, if you want to be an
expert in all of these fields, you too
must commit to doing the bare minimum by
getting a PhD, that is the first step
that also grants you authority in all of
these realms. Now, because we are trying
to make the scientific landscape more
inclusive, you can also opt to not get a
PhD because you have PubMed. As is
evident by every forum and comment
section on the internet, the
availability of PubMed to the average
person is the best thing to ever happen
to the world. Thanks to this, now the
average individual can teach themselves
science and thereby have really reliable
opinions on things like vaccines and
nutrition. In fact, I think we need to
increase the availability of engineering
material. Why are we only having bridges
and airplanes built by people with
advanced degrees when we could leverage
the collective knowledge of the average
internet commentator? Now, some of you
might not want to go full in on the
science, and that's because you're too
stupid to understand how smart all of
this is, but that's just fine. You fence
sitters can certainly just hang out in
the middle ground and decide to do a
little bit of science as it suits you.
Optimal science-based tactics will
certainly grow you more, but so will
doing what works for you and doing
whatever your personal preference is.
Just like with physics, engineering,
chemistry, results will absolutely not
be tanked by just doing science where
you feel like it and winging the rest.
Whatever shortfall you have in your
non-scientific application is going to
be more than made up for by the little
dash of science that you decide to use.
Now, another cope or uh sound conclusion
that you can make is that your lack of
gains is something to do with your
genetics. In the face of not seeing any
growth despite your adherence to the
evidence, you can just say that other
people are more genetically blessed than
you. And instead of trying something
tried and true, when you see that your
chest isn't growing, stay faithful to
the science by doing your weird chest
flap thingies while holding a handle
that's not attached to anything. The
real plot twist is that you actually are
jacked and everybody should aspire to
look like you, a naturally jacked
individual, using science-based methods
to attain the physique of an average
high school middle distance runner. Now,
you can also go all the way and embrace
the black pill fully by saying that
getting jacked is actually impossible.
You could say Hugh Jackman's
transformation from a sedentary drama
kid to having the physique of an average
swimmer is actually unattainable and
only the byproduct of drugs plus elite
genetics. And since gaining muscle and
strength requires you to do something so
immoral, the only logical conclusion is
that getting jacked is lame anyways and
a sign of a dysfunctional and oppressive
society. You're sure not going to play
into that. And at this point, you can
order your PhD in sociology from the
same department that gave Matt Wenning
his PhD. You can hang it on the wall
next to your online IQ test and sleep
soundly that you are a faithful adherent
to the science.